My name is Afrika Afeni.
Afrika, spelled with a K,
and Afeni, after Afeni Shakur,
a member of the Black Panther Party
and mother of Tupac Shakur.
As you might imagine, I grew up
talking about race with my family.
My father built bookshelves
in the living room
of our Brooklyn apartment,
and my parents filled those shelves
with the books of Black authors
whose words we were unfortunately
unlikely to encounter outside of our home.
I have Alex Haley's autograph.
Alex Haley, writer of "Roots,"
and transcriber of
"The Autobiography of Malcolm X."
As you can see in the picture,
Alex Haley referred to me
as his “little sister.”
Talking and reading with my family
about race was commonplace,
and many of the children in my community
and students in my schools
look just like me.
Even though my parents taught me
as much as they could about race,
I had not experienced
having these conversations
with people who were
racially different from me.
When I went away
to a predominantly white college,
I was not prepared
for the emotions that I experienced
when having these conversations.
For example, when another student asked,
"Why do you need a Black History Month
and why isn't there
a White History Month,"
I found myself feeling very frustrated.
Learning to have conversations
with people about race
across racial difference
has been a part of my own
deepening learning journey.
Though it can be hard,
let me encourage you.
Having conversations about race is just
another hard thing we can learn to do.
I know this because I'm an educator.
I have been for over 20 years.
I have supported teachers
and students around the country
to teach and learn in ways that honor
the dignity and worth of all people.
In this work, it is clear
that having conversations about race,
particularly with our students,
is not a luxury but a necessity.
And there's no better place
to begin having these conversations
than with our students.
It's not that adults can't learn
to have healthy conversations about race,
but the minds of children
are more malleable.
This is why it's easier to learn
to do challenging things
like play an instrument,
ride a bike, play a sport
or to become fluent
in a new language when we're young.
If we teach children to be comfortable
talking about race from the beginning,
they will likely have fewer falls
and missteps, less baggage,
less to unlearn, and biased ideas
will be less likely to take hold.
We can then imagine a future
where we can have productive dialogue
and discussions across our differences.
Today, I'm going to share with you
four steps you can take
to do challenging things,
particularly having
conversations about race:
identify your challenge;
find your support network;
prepare; and begin.
In my work with educators
around the country,
when we explore what's challenging
about having conversations
with students about race,
they often say things like,
"I don't have the resources
to have these conversations."
In fact, in EdWeek Research Center's
2020 special report,
"Big Ideas for Confronting
Racism in Education,"
though 81 percent of the more
than 800 educators surveyed
identified as anti-racist educators,
only 14 percent of them said that they had
both the training and the resources
to have these conversations with students.
Though this statistic holds true,
there are several organizations
that provide free instructional resources
that support lessons and dialogue
with students about race.
So access to instructional resources
isn't the true challenge.
If we're honest with ourselves,
it's easier to identify
external factors as challenges
than it is for us to accept responsibility
to influence what is
within our locus of control.
When I go deeper with educators,
they share that the underlying
challenge is actually fear.
They're afraid of saying the wrong thing
or doing harm when talking
with students about race.
This is understandable,
especially considering the history
and current manifestations
of substantial racial harm
in this country.
But when we identify the true challenge,
not the school or the lack
of resources, but fear,
is an essential first step.
Once we can name what's
at the heart of our challenge,
we can begin to overcome it
with the next step:
finding our support network.
Too often attempts to begin
having conversations
with students about race fail
because the fear
of making mistakes takes over.
When we try to do this work
on our own and we face a challenge,
say, for example, a student says something
or asks a question that we're not prepared
to address or answer,
in our minds, we can say things like,
"Oh, this is uncomfortable.
I don't like being uncomfortable.
I don't think I want to do this anymore."
It's important for us
to be surrounded by a community of people
who are committed to doing this work.
My colleague Jenna Chandler-Ward,
a white woman and cofounder
of “Teaching While White,”
facilitates racial accountability spaces.
She regularly hears
from white teachers and students
that they are afraid
to say the wrong thing.
She shares with them
that she herself has remained silent
to avoid conflict and for fear
of making things worse.
Jenna says if we are not
intentionally seeking people
to hold up a mirror
and hold us accountable,
we'll end up surrounding ourselves
with people who affirm our beliefs
instead of challenging us
to see something more.
The more perspectives we have,
the broader our understanding will be,
especially from people
who are at different points
of racial identity development.
If we are part of a group of people
who are doing this work together,
we have a place to take that discomfort
and work through it.
It will help us to remember
that we're not alone
and help us to feel less isolated.
Once we find our support network,
we can prepare to have conversations
with students about race.
When the student
I mentioned earlier asked me
why there was a Black History Month
and not a White History Month,
I experienced a whole range of emotions:
confusion, hurt, anger.
Similarly, just as I experienced
a range of emotions,
so will your students and so will you.
Expect it so you can be prepared.
For this work to be sustainable,
it is important that we prepare
to navigate these conversations
in our learning communities.
We will want to intentionally envision
how these conversations
will look and feel.
What emotions might the discussions
bring up for our students?
What agreements
might we need to have in place
before we have these discussions?
How will you respond to questions,
comments and resistance?
How will you repair
any harm that may be done?
You'll want to feel comfortable
responding in the moment
instead of reacting
if the discussion doesn't go
the way you hoped.
Once you prepare,
you'll be ready to begin.
Just as in starting anything new,
it can be messy,
and you'll make mistakes
because you're human.
Making mistakes can feel scary,
especially because our work is so public.
When we push through that fear, however,
we can teach students
to have conversations about race
and help them to unpack
their misperceptions.
In this work with teachers,
it feels like some people
are waiting for the perfect moment
when a racially conscious
version of themselves will appear
before they begin engaging in this work.
That version of yourself
has to be purposely developed and formed,
and that moment is now.
When we engage in conversations
with our students about race,
we can help to expand their thinking
and equip them with the language and tools
that they need to see themselves clearly
and to recognize and value the histories,
perspectives and experiences
of people who are unlike them.
They'll be prepared to help us
build and sustain a truly just society
where we all contribute
to the well-being of everyone
in our human family.
Remember, having conversations about race
is just another hard thing
we can learn to do,
one courageous step at a time.
Thank you.
(Applause)